بعد مرور اكثر من 30 عاما على انهيار
الاتحاد السوفيتي تعود الان الى شاشات
السينما الروسيه الشخصيات الكرتونيه
السوفيتيه الكلاسيكيه بعد اعاده احياء
العديد من هذه الاعمال من جديد
بدانا في شهر يناير بعرض فيلم الذي نال
حضورا كبيرا
ثلاثه عوامل متزامنه ساعدت على زياده
شعبيه هذا الفيلم وهي اولا نقص الافلام
المعروضه وبسبب شعبيه الشخصيه الكرتونيه
السوفييتيه
ولان عرض الفيلم تزامن مع عطله راس السنه
فيلم الرسوم الكرتونيه السوفيتيه
تشوبراشكا احد الافلام التي اعيد احيائها
من جديد الان حتى ما الارقام القياسيه
بنسبه المشاهده في روسيا التي بلغت نحو
عشره ملايين مشاهده واحتل المركز الاول في
شباك التذاكر بين الافلام الروسيه بعد
ايام فقط من اطلاقه
النادي السينمائي الدار الذي يديره الفنان
الشعبي الروسي اوليج اسس من قبل مخرجين
الحقبه السوفيتيه ويعرض بشكل دائم الافلام
من تلك الفتره والتي تلقى حضورا كبيرا حتى
الان حاله الحنين لدى المواطنين الروس
ليست فقط الى الاعمال الفنيه في الحقبه
السوفيتيه وانما الى كل ما يتعلق بهذه
الفتره من تفاصيل الحياه اليوميه خبراء
فنيون تحدثوا عن ان نجاح هذه الافلام الان
يعود الى وجود حاله من الحنين الى الاعمال
والشخصيات في الحقبه السوفيتيه من قبل
الصغار والكبار وحتى المتقاعدين من الروس
وسط غياب للافلام الهوليوديه بعد حظر
عرضها على الشاشات في روسيا
كاتيا طعم العربيه موسكو